salve all'improvviso come entrare così
ad avere tante persone davanti alla
bellezza all'improvviso io partirei
subito con un'opera d'arte
quest'opera d'arte a autore sconosciuto
e a titoli di diverso in diversi modi si
può chiamare i diversi modi in diverse
lingue si può chiamare lampo si può
chiamare saetta si può chiamare fulmine
autore sconosciuto perché attualmente
noi lo possiamo anche dare alla natura
come paternità dell'opera per ora c'è
anche altri che se la contendono la
paternità dell'opera di cassa di questo
tipo non la vogliono traina trascinare
verso verso altri credi ed è giusto che
sia così perché è la libertà di credo e
di espressione talmente potente fin
dall'inizio questa spesso segnale nel
cielo che in realtà era praticamente
impossibile resistere più che altro
perché non solo aveva questa immagine
meravigliosa no da sempre dagli albori
ma soprattutto perché era molto molto
pericoloso stiamo parlando di 200 mila
volt di energia che possono arrivare
sulla terra che si scaricano dal cielo
quindi da un punto più alto a noi quindi
veniamo noi magari dominati da questo
questo fenomeno e lo subiamo nel momento
in cui lo subiamo non penso che si possa
resistere a questa questa potenza quindi
in realtà noi abbiamo anche la paura di
qualcosa che ha una forza incredibile
quando si ha paura di qualcosa
probabilmente si mitizza evidentemente
si mitizza
questa questo questo fenomeno non
a questo fenomeno nessuno potrebbe
resistere animali piante uomini e quindi
diventa un dio quando qualcosa di questo
tipo diventa un dio ci sono delle menti
creativi di solito che cercano anche di
pre far diventare questo dio
controllabile o comunque di dargli una
valenza ogni volta contemporaneo di
dargli una metafora utilizzabile no è
quindi per questo diventa il colpo di
fulmine
il colpo di fulmine che è una delle fasi
essenziali della creazione un momento in
cui ti arriva qualcosa dall'esterno che
tu non hai nessun modo di controllare e
al quale non si è assolutamente
preparato una maleducazione dell'idea
che arriva in un momento che tu sia
fragile che tu sia depresso che tu sia
super attivo che tu sia felice arriva
questo questo colpo di fulmine colpo i
forni a un certo punto proprio perché
diventa una bellissima espressione per
parlare di amore per parlare di bellezza
per parlare di qualcosa che entra la
nostra percezione diventa anche una
maniera per una maniera uno studio
diventa una scienza per riuscire ad
accaparrarsi l'attenzione riuscirà ad
arrivare alle menti delle persone è così
che allora si dice vabbè creiamo il
colpo di fulmine in laboratorio
non parlo di tesla parlò di un colpo di
fulmine molto più metaforico e quindi
inizia tutta una preparazione che ha
fatto nascere in realtà quelle che sono
a volte le cose più belle di opere
all'interno delle opere d'arte
e questo in tutte le forme d'arte
io non parlo in realtà della della
creatività applicata della pubblicità
dove il colpo di fulmine deve durare 30
secondi perché voi avete 30 secondi per
vederla deve essere veloce perché
guardando un manifesto dovete essere
veloci
io parlo del colpo di fulmine nell'arte
pura quella che si dice definisce così
nella musica sono il famoso attacco
la intro di una canzone immagino che
anche voi abbiate comprato l'album del
vostro artista preferito poi avete
ascoltato quest'album e c'è questo
maledetto pezzo di 15 secondi che si
chiama intro che uno ascolta e dice
button
fatene un pezzo da cinque minuti non
lasciatelo di 15 secondi
quello è il colpo di fulmine che si crea
in modo da generare poi tutto il resto
inutile dire che nel cinema la stessa
cosa
i primi alcuni lo fanno diventare molto
molto lungo come i primi venti minuti
salvate il soldato ryan
come altri accadimenti nei libri
l'incipit è tutto dedicato molto spesso
a catturare l'attenzione nel primo
momento colpo di fulmine quindi diventa
una scienza ma rimane una cosa che
comunque in natura che si ha idea o che
sia fenomeno naturale è incontrollabile
e maleducatissimo quando è idea colpo di
fulmine di accoglie anche quando siete
nei posti più intimi e ci sono degli
accadimenti in realtà che sono anche che
possono anche generare un colpo di
fulmine che possono generare un
cambiamento
io sono qui per raccontarvi il mio
accadimento come l'accadimento potrebbe
appartenere a qualsiasi altra persona
pensiamo per esempio io l'altro giorno
ascoltavo un un discorso stavo per dire
speech di storaro di vittorio storaro
mitologico cinematografo anche questo
cosa dire cinematografo e che ha fatto
la storia del cinema direttore della
fotografia che raccontava che in una
passeggiata con sua moglie fidanzatino a
roma entra in san luigi dei francesi
vicino piazza navona una chiesa
bellissima ma nascosta e guarda e si
trova davanti alla al quadro dove viene
raffigurata l'investitura di san matteo
la chiamata di san matteo da parte di
gesù cristo e questo quadro del
caravaggio che probabilmente un nome che
voi conoscete michelangelo merisi da
caravaggio in quel momento cambia la
storia dell'arte c'è un'immagine
classica una composizione classica viene
totalmente rotta da un fascio di luce
nella parte superiore del quadro io non
ve l'ho portata perché essendo un
artista se porto caravaggio io sparisco
e quindi immaginate la c'è questo fascio
di luce pazzesco e storaro lì davanti
diventa direttore della fotografia
storaro li copia caravaggio inventando
la luce che ricopre marlon brando nel
nel monologo finale di apocalypse now
una cosa proprio del dell'ultimo minuto
questa cosa è il colpo di fulmine
concentrato in un momento concentrato in
una in un'opera d'arte
e a me è capitata una cosa simile in
realtà io ero disegnatore da tanti anni
lavoravo in pubblicità era un momento
strano della mia vita di una casa molto
piccola e ci è entrato per motivi
sentimentali di rottura allora entrò in
questa casa mi sento che dovevo fare
qualcosa nel 2006 e decido che dovevo
smettere di disegnare non smetterò mai
ma comunque dovevo iniziare
qualcos'altro e passare a qualcosa
diciamo più nobili per tecnica per
affine affinità anche con con artisti
molto più elevati e deciso di dipingere
di iniziare a dipingere esco pomeriggio
martedì vado compro tutto tornò a casa
spacchetto colori tele e non ci sono i
pennelli ora in quel momento se tu vai a
comprare gli ingredienti per una torta
torni a casa e non ce lo zucchero rischi
di impazzire
perché devi cambiare totalmente la tua
visione ora questo mia mi poneva davanti
a una grande scelta aspettare il giorno
dopo o far sì che questa cosa diventasse
il mio colpo di fulmine
non potevo farlo si ma volevo che la
cosa comunque non mi fermasse vi faccio
vedere una cosa che vi spiega da lì in
poi cosa è successo
ok grazie ma la cosa bellissima che è
successa in quel momento e che come
faccio un'altra metafora io forse la
giorno per questo in questo modo era
come se mancando il sostegno del
pennello che aveva tenuto in piedi aveva
tenuta agganciata all'arte generazioni
di artisti
in realtà come se avessero tolto un
oggetto sotto di me una piccola sedia io
fosse rimasto sospeso cioè due modi di
rimanere sospese o se e stato impiccato
oppure stai volando e io ho iniziato a
volare sulle mani è diventata una un
accadimento che ha fatto sì che io
capissi lentamente ma nello stesso
momento immediatamente che le cose
arrivano per un certo per un certo
motivo è che ogni volta devono essere
prese con estrema naturalezza ma anche
seguite allora cosa succede iniziò a
dipingere con le dita e iniziò a
studiare il corpo come espressione
perché dico se mi hanno tolto uno
strumento oggi che gli strumenti cieli
aggiungono sempre di più o nello stesso
strumento si aggiungono di
microstrumenti eccetera eccetera in quel
momento io mi son sentito invece
togliere qualsiasi appoggio tecnologico
qualsiasi tool a me per essere libero
allora ho studiato il corpo le reazioni
del corpo il fatto che è diretto il
rapporto tra quello che sentiamo e
quello che tocchiamo quello che ci tocca
e vi faccio vedere alcune cose io per
esempio ho studiato molto pensando al
corpo quella che la gestualità che fa
parte di noi italiani la nostra bellezza
anche all'estero il fatto che noi siamo
quelli che vengono indicati come persone
giocolieri nell'aria con le nostre mani
e perché probabilmente eravamo da sempre
un popolo siamo da sempre un popolo di
mercanti e quindi ogni volta che
dovevamo anche dire a uno straniero che
cosa volevamo cosa non volevamo quanto
ne volevamo di qualcosa utilizzavamo vai
vieni da me ne due no non fare così e
queste cose eccetera eccetera
allora questo meraviglioso mi ha fatto
scoprire un giorno che c'era una
contraddizione in un segno molto
particolare delle mani e ho dipinto
questo quadro questo quadro si chiama
peace award pace e guerra perdono male i
titoli derivano in questo caso da una
mostra san francisco dove io immagino
che il segno di vista un cerci l'ho
quello che lui ha portato alla notorietà
della pace
basta girarlo per avere io in questo
momento vi sto mandando a quel paese in
maniera anglosassone sta prendendo molto
piede questa cosa questo segno era prima
solo inglese adesso sta diventando un
segno comune nello stesso uomo perché
l'uomo concentra all'interno di sé la
capacità di decidere da che parte stare
e nello stesso momento la semplicità di
questo gesto magari ci racconta che
basta poco
forse davvero il dialogo per riuscire a
cambiare certe cose nello stesso momento
e ci dà anche la fragilità di quello che
il gesto tutto relazionato al fisico
perché quello che mi era accaduto come
accadimento momentaneo come colpo di
fulmine era accaduto al mio figlio
in questo caso per esempio ho voluto
parlare dell'ideale del fatto che di
solito noi siamo portati a spingere un
ideale a portare una bandiera per
diverse motivazioni sono religiose sono
politiche sono personali sono come dice
di commerciali ma nello stesso momento
non non dovremmo dimenticare almeno
questo il suggerimento che dietro
qualsiasi battaglia qualsiasi modo che
qualsiasi idea che noi portiamo avanti
c'è una cosa fondamentale l'uomo quello
che all'uomo di qualsiasi età e per
questo che uso tra l'altro la stessa
figura per non darvi troppi troppi
soggetti troppi protagonisti no è un
simbolo e la stessa figura che ogni
volta troviamo muovendola in maniera
differente
in questo caso se combatti per qualsiasi
cosa anche dietro un logo c'è l'uomo c'è
l'uomo che lavora c'è l'uomo che alla
fine avrà il risultato di questa tua
cosa è quello stesso uomo sei tu quindi
si chiude quasi in un cerchio ultima
ultima è la sostanza delle idee
secondo me questo allora questo io l'ho
portato perché in realtà è un po la
traduzione di quello che è successo a me
quindi la nuvola lavorando in pubblicità
magari a volte odiato le icone però in
questo caso la nuvola dico in inglese
permesso il balloon è una cosa che di
solito contiene i pensieri le idee c'è
nel cartella di malato pin
ok la lampadina e all'interno di un ball
1 ma in ogni caso il balloon questa cosa
è diventata fisica è diventata pesante
perché non è detto che avere un idea sia
positivo
la responsabilità di usare quella idea
di saperla gestire quell idea quello può
farla diventare positiva ci sono tante
idee che ci prendono per i fondelli
altrettante idee che passano in onore
non le vediamo in questo caso io mi sono
sentito di comunicare che per sostenere
un'idea ci vuole una forza non solo
fisica ma un intensità energetica e
intellettuale
io spero che anche a voi arrivi un'idea
del genere che lo sappiate sostenere che
sappiate farla diventare la vostra
bellezza grazie